well I think that to redesign the world
we have to start by creating equality
among people and we have to try to
achieve equal capacities people physical
capacities equal emotional capacities
and an equal intellectual capacities
with individuals and in order to do that
we have to build on well nourished
children between the ages minus 9 to the
first 24 months of life we can do that
we can really change the way we have
developing countries like mexico de
thirty-five percent of your people over
the children under five are
undernourished and that is a developing
country one of the 12 / con largest
economies in the world imagine the poor
countries and the situation they're
living so we have to focus on creating
equality capacity equalist among people
around the world